[Music]
you get your back blown out to clb this
weekend or what
yeah dude
there's no better music
you get your cheeks clapped to get
pegged then
then that album
yeah that's what happened when the drake
album released
boyfriends worldwide were woken up
and
girlfriends had the double vinyl lp laid
out
on a bed of rose petals with a strap-on
next to it
and then every boyfriend's like it's
tonight tonight she's like yes babe
happy drop day happy clb day
yeah
[Music]
everyone that has ever complained about
moaning on the podcast yeah this is your
worst nightmare just got a dose of real
moaning
and that wasn't even the pegging part
that was just putting the little heart
in the hairline
[Music]
[Laughter]
why are these even on here
you sick [ __ ]
yeah it's the clb library
dondo i felt healed me
was amazing i actually gave it
yeah a real shot yeah and i loved it go
ahead something no some people were like
oh this reminds me of like corny
christian music i grew up doing i can i
can see that but what clb
no
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm too sexy i don't
have churches
too sexy is a classic youth pastor track
that song was called you're too sexy
oh was it
yeah from pastors to children oh right
right right yeah
[Laughter]
you're
too sexy for my robe
too sexy for this booth
uh too sexy for the truth i don't know
something like that i like that yeah no
donda i felt was like a healing
experience people said it was mid
how
i think maybe just like too long and too
i don't know i think people
just wanted an opinion you know like
that's not an album that you just put on
and listen to his homework and then have
an opinion like you have to like
hear that at the right time you know i i
didn't listen to it i waited to listen
to it until like one in the morning on a
random
friday night
or like it wasn't even friday i was like
during the week and then i got stuck on
uh wait what did it come out last
thursday the watch uh donda was it last
thursday sunday last sunday i can't even
remember sunday morning yeah so what's
music time that's right yeah he knows
when to drop man people love listening
to music on sunday morning you can
listen to hurricane at 7 00 am oh yeah
definitely but that's probably the only
song
you could listen to it wasn't a
hurricane actually in any any sort of
occasion yeah yeah yeah that's i got
stuck on that at like one in the morning
in the living room i just kept looping
it
can we go into the next song i'm like no
we're staying here i'm just standing in
the yeah staying in the living room
half naked just
this was me on sunday morning
listening to hurricane like this
chelsea said babe can we go to the [ __ ]
let's see right here what does it say
read it listen this part don't let me
drown what's
[Music]
yeah it's my favorite part
[Music]
yeah that's me
yeah and then clb came out on thursday
yeah typical
this is a little [ __ ] time to drop
yeah
and i know
there's like i think people are so angry
because
i think boyfriends worldwide were angry
as hell because the album was just like
more drake and they're just tired of it
they've been listening to drake for
years they've been getting punished by
their significant other for years
there's probably people that got
together during like his second album
and now they're still together on this
album and they're like drake can you
[ __ ] make something else i'm going
crazy right so i think that was a lot of
the frustration is a lot of men weeping
world it's like drake grief like
they're just grieving that this is gonna
be the playlist in the car and if they
work out together
but you don't think that
because i would say the guys are equally
as into it
oh i would say guys were more into this
album
yeah i'm just i just mean all the rap
nerds that were on like twitter
complaining and [ __ ] right you know
actually no they don't have girlfriends
[Laughter]
those guys are gonna [ __ ] it up
for the rest of the year yeah girls are
gonna put that on and they're gonna be
like
you know dracus doesn't take any risks
she's gonna be like right
so you're not into pegging or
you know i agree with you i think i
think dudes are into it yeah yeah do you
like it
clb yeah no not really oh there's like
two songs okay i liked on it what songs
did you like i don't know
i don't i didn't like it enough to look
at the [ __ ] title got it
no i mean like i put the whole thing on
in the car and then a couple of songs i
was like alright cool all right cool
yeah i don't know that's what i was
expecting i didn't realize it was gonna
be i mean maybe i should have
i should have guessed that it was gonna
be like an entire album of like ballads
almost yeah sex music just like sex
music i should have figured it was with
the cover and the title yeah but for
some reason i thought it was just gonna
be an album of bangers and i was wrong
and instead i got banged to it yeah yeah
that's the album you suck dick too yeah
yeah i
i listened to part of it the night it
dropped and then i wanted to listen to
it again the next day in the car
and i'm trying
my production system i
i put on like the first song i'm like
all right man i just hold out my hand
like he's got to hold my hand now and
then we're just dying laughing at dudes
driving to clb like holding their hands
beneath the window
monkey style yeah
on the center console
oh this is a good one yeah this one's
down uh squeezing squeezing his hand to
the feet yeah
264 oh
hard sorry your hands are so clammy
why are you sweating curious
why are you sweating man are you gay
why are your hands sweating while you
hold my hand dude don't be gay
yeah i mean did there there were some
songs on there i'm trying to remember
which ones i liked
he can write his ass off i i you know i
sort of like the kanye beef element
i think they're just trying to ham that
up
yeah i think so too yeah but i do like
it
yeah i love it
yeah little between little t yeah a
little t between a list celebs like that
it's always fun because it's never
direct you know no we actually we do
have
some some cringe lyrics a presentation
of uh the cringiest lyrics i don't know
why people are so mad about the i'm a
lesbian girl me too i thought it was
kind of dope
were you tucking your hair back yeah it
was like
i mean i was like girl me too
[Laughter]
girl
girl you and then me too i was like
yeah it's oh my yeah
you see the look i'm going for
all right let's see what lyrics people
are mad about ah that's old drake
and the dirt that they threw on my name
turned to soil and i grew up out about
it
okay
is that corny that's not that bad nah
and also on girl i'm a like a lesbian
girl me too it's like
all the dudes mad about that line that
line isn't even for you yeah right
wait why were guys mad about that line
that's like if you went on like the the
subreddit like the hip hop had subreddit
so many comments like did drake really
just do this
are you [ __ ] kidding me bro this is
so corny it's not ruined my thursday
yeah that's like being mad about like
olivia rodrigo music like that [ __ ]
ain't for you man
that song we were pretty pissed about
the paramore thing i mean that's
different
that's the that's thievery
you know
like that uh that line to me was like
jack's you know
uh
uh and with a best friend and like the
threesome song yeah yeah but i was like
that's what that's for yeah you know
it's i'm picturing like all these nerds
online be like this line is kill corny
and then it cuts to a drake concert and
it's just all women singing that song
and he's like i don't give a [ __ ]
you just me the one dude in the crowd
like this line is goofy dude
cheese ball
whatever all right this one
yeah
talking all the [ __ ] you don't been
through yeah okay
yeah that's the one this line bangs say
that you a lesbian girl me too okay next
what's next
so you belong to the streets but the
streets belong to me yeah that one i
that one i heard that when i was a
little bit like uh
really
i mean yeah really i mean this dude
lives in an embassy
yeah that's true that's like i'm just
saying he says all this crazy stuff and
to us it's corny but we
i feel like that's how regular everyone
is compared to him like he can say this
[ __ ] and like he feels like it's real
right that's how like popping he is
right we can't relate to that at all
yeah streets don't belong to you dude
yeah
yeah he's like watch he just goes
outside
you know i don't know no that's true
that is a good point
but yeah it is pretty [ __ ] corny next
why they always act like we can fix it
with a meeting all that linking up man
i'm a seawolf i'ma see you when i see
you yeah that's a little
[Laughter]
i just feel like there's no punch line
there
like yeah they do act like that this is
just about how much zoom meetings suck
yeah yeah that's what it is if anything
people should relate to this one exactly
yeah
[ __ ] nine to five or should be like
yes
that's gonna be a tick tock in two weeks
what it'll be like the song playing with
like
zoom meetings and then this line will
come on and be like
man i'ma see you when i see you yeah
hell yeah and record hell yeah
the link the linkedin community is gonna
go crazy on this oh yeah
all right what else we got
standing on your own is when you realize
when all the lights go out that's when
you see the real
okay what
hold on
oh it's it is clb
i don't understand this one
um
maybe it's like like
when
like the spotlight's off you you see who
your real friends are type thing
yeah the next line was realize realize
real yeah
yeah there you go oh
see in that in that way yeah that is
pretty cheesy i thought that second line
is about like people jerking each other
off or something
i don't know on paper it's like it's
hard to interpret man
this is kind of the lights go out and
all you hear is
yeah
they should hear this
[Music]
babe do you like your strap-on
i can't believe you got my name on it
this is kind of like reading someone's
stand up
it's just not the same at all it's true
this is not the same
that'd be funny if people posted you
know like the stand-up quote pictures
yeah i'm on stage and then it's a quote
yeah they should do that with drake
then we should make those then people
just confuse it for like entrepreneurial
accounts
exactly
like what is did drake start like a
business or something
all over like alpha men's instagram
accounts yeah you know
real alpha real men no sigmas
yeah yeah and it's just this and dudes
are like yo plus plus 100 plus 100 or
whatever plus one
what do you mean 100 like dudes in the
comments like it's agreeing with it like
oh yeah dude
no one really understands it
standing on your own is when you realize
dude that's so true man whenever the
lights go out i hate when the lights go
out and there's no real
real guys
there's no real guys there's no real
guys
loyalty is priceless and it's all i need
can't burn a bridge just to light my way
okay
okay yeah this is kind of hallmarky
you could def put that on like a sunset
yeah image yeah yeah
all right what else we got
and that's it and that's the end damn i
love that corporate powerpoint yeah
that's great
and this is why i think clb is the best
yeah of 2021. thank you for watching my
presentation yeah that i mean i get that
it was a template but that looked pretty
financed
i could have sworn a graphics coming up
next
you